the atlas and wonderland films have some
of the most stunning
beautiful visuals in disney movies
however
things didn't exactly look that way on
set a lot of cgi was used to help build
the vast and detailed world we see
on screen sometimes actors would only be
interacting with a few tangible items on
set
while other times they had nothing at
all except endless green screen sets
so let's take a peek at what these films
look like before the disney magic was
added
wait this is my dream when alice first
meets the mad hatter she is still
shrunken down
and takes a trip on the hatter's hat and
shoulder but how was this effect
achieved well they shot alice separately
on green screen props
she was actually hanging off of a giant
hat they built on set
as well as sitting on a giant pad that
acted as the mad hatter's shoulder
plus both these props were on motion
rakes that simulated walking
your carriage my lady the epic final
battle between alice and the jabberwocky
looks epic
but behind the scenes was anything but
alice actress mia vashikawska was
actually fighting against nothing at all
she was all alone on a green screen
stage
swinging her sword aimlessly at nothing
but air
i can slay the job when you first see
the red queen
the first thing you'll notice is the
size of her head it is
disproportionately bigger than the rest
of her body
the effects team achieved this by simply
making her head and neck
bigger in editing they also gave her
body more of an hourglass shape to help
balance the giant head better
when alice is sneaking into the red
queen's castle the first
obstacle she must overcome is a moat
filled with heads
she leaps across them which she actually
did in real life
mia was actually jumping on giant head
props they built on set
that moved as if they were in water
which were then replaced with cgi
to complete the effect there's only one
way across
alice falling down the rabbit hole was
accomplished with a blend of live action
and cgi
the entire environment is comprised of
computer generated animation
while alice falling is a mix between a
live stunt person
bouncing off a pad and a cg double the
effects team did a great job creating
our first glimpse at wonderland
the bander snatch is the first big bad
creature alice encounters in wonderland
while you may think some aspects of the
chase scene were real in reality
only alice was real the bandersnatch is
completely cg
along with the surrounding environment
mia vasikowska was on a green screen
treadmill to simulate her running from
the creature
not quite as epic as the final shot it's
only a dream
nothing can hurt me one of the most
fantastical
and beautiful scenes and through the
looking glass comes when alice is
traveling back in time and she crosses
an
ocean full of her memories the scene was
a technical challenge
that took over 900 terabytes of storage
to complete the vfx team used rough
season surfing as reference material to
create the oceans
the only practical element was alice on
a rig and a blue screen
set you cannot fit in your eyes against
time
another incredibly impressive effect in
through the looking glass
is when the world rushed over it was a
massive undertaking that took
multiple steps and tons of tweaking to
get just right
the vfx team used a lot of real world
references of rush
to create the right look for the effect
it was such a massive undertaking that
it took
two years from the first test shot to
the completed product
that kind of dedication results in the
amazing visuals we see
on screen the tweedles may be twins but
the characters are actually played by
the same actor
matt lucas portrayed both characters in
the films he would play the part of one
of the brothers
then do another performance as the other
brother which the editors would then
stitch together
he also had to constantly be wearing a
green screen fat suit as well as stilts
for all the scenes with shrunken alice
there's a small detail about the mad
hatter's appearance that you may have
overlooked
his eyes are larger than normal the vfx
team
actually manually enhanced their size in
post-production
this was a small yet important feature
that helped portray the character's odd
quirky style it's you
one of the most iconic scenes in the
original alice in wonderland is when she
shrinks and grows
so recreating it in the live action
version was an important scene
they used a mix of cg elements live
action and camera tricks to achieve the
effects
when alice shrinks the entire room is cg
along with alice's body
for when she grows big the crew built a
small set that made mia vashikawska
appear to be giant it's only a dream one
of the funniest yet ten
scenes in the film comes when the red
queen is interrogating her frog's
servants
the behind the scenes is even funnier
with red queen actress helena bonham
carter
speaking to green frog statues it's odd
to look at
and will definitely change the way you
view this scene
the cheshire cat is one of the most
unique characters in the film
especially with regards to how he moves
and interacts with the
environment it was a completely cgi
character
created by the movie's vfx team and when
cheshire interacted with alice
there was a person in a green screen
suit as a stand-in
performing the action i never get
involved in politics
knave of hearts is a very tall character
which required some effects trickery to
achieve
actor crispin glover was on stilts the
entire time he was filming for this
character
the effects team then digitally extended
his limbs in post creating the lanky
character we see on screen
this is a perfect example of how
practical effects and digital
alterations
can work together in harmony you're all
mad
the mad hatter execution scene featured
a lot of characters and actors
and was a challenge to film the crowd
was shot separately from the principal
actors
and the environment was completely cg
senior visual effects supervisor
ken ralston explained what made it so
difficult
the execution scene was a challenge for
all the different interaction of the
characters
live action characters animated
characters hybrid characters like the
tweedles and stain
the magical land of wonderland is full
of stunning
visuals and beautiful colors in the
movie it was completely created with cg
when alice first enters wonderland the
only real elements
are her and the staircase she is walking
on the vfx team did a great job
creating the mystical land and giving it
a memorable look
wait this is my dream alice through the
looking glass introduced us to
characters that represent
seconds of time it's a unique concept
that the vfx
team built from the ground up we also
see the seconds combined to 4 minutes
which then combine to form hours this
means the minutes and hours are made up
of the individual
seconds characters these miniscule
artisans are my
seconds when alice travels back in time
she finds the mad hatter roaming around
in town surprisingly this was actually a
practical set that they built
the only vfx used were to create the sky
and background
it's one of the few times they actually
used more of a practical set for a
wonderland scene
and it looks great have we missed the
second time
alice enters wonderland she enters a
room that is a lot more stocked than the
shrinking room in the first movie
it looks like a normal room with some
wonderland flair
but it may surprise you to learn that
the entire room was computer generated
alice was shot on a blue screen and the
room was animated in post-production
what has happened in the same room alice
enters after going through the mirror
there is a giant chess board she lands
on the chess pieces are completely cg
so to give vasikowska the correct line
of sight they had people in green screen
suits holding up
giant poles to mimic the height of the
chess pieces
all my horses oh my men to the rescue
now knowing how these movies were filmed
you might watch them a bit differently
the next time
these actors did a fantastic job
especially considering how much they
filmed on empty sets with nothing but
green screen
we would imagine it's not easy
pretending to talk to an imaginary cat
which scene surprised you the most